alexandra d'amour s'intéresse aux
recyclages et nous demandent que
proposent les partis pour que les
efforts des québécois concernant la
réduction des matières résiduelles soit
soutenue plastique bonne question à
laquelle je vais essayer de répondre
brièvement au parti libéral on rappelle
qu'une subvention de 10 millions $ a été
accordée au centre de tri juste avant
les élections
le plq s'engage aussi à bannir les spas
et des bars et des restaurants installés
plus de bacs de recyclage près des
poubelles publiques et à faire en sorte
qu enfin le polystyrène puisse être
recyclés au pq on souhaite adopter une
loi cadre sur l'économie circulaire
ainsi qu'une stratégie de réduction des
bouteilles d'eau c'est pour ça que dans
son cadre financier le pq a réservé une
enveloppe de 2 millions $ par année pour
aider les municipalités installé plus de
fontaines publiques
une mise aussi beaucoup sur la
sensibilisation québec solidaire de son
côté d'accord avec le principe d'une loi
cadre qui encadrerait l'économie
circulaire mais souhaiterait qu'elle
s'attaque aussi à l'obsolescence
programmée
q s propose aussi d'étendre le système
des consignes notamment aux bouteilles
de vin et aux bouteilles d'eau enfin la
cac qui n'a pas pris d'engagement sur le
sujet mais bon il reste encore quelques
jours à la campagne électorale voilà
j'espère qu'il se répondent à votre
question
si vous en avez d'autres n'hésitez pas à
nous écrire à vos élections arobas radio
canada.ca